I posted this on my Instagram stories today
because Hirsch Goldberg is one of these victims
that they found killed in Gaza.
They were hostages from October 7th.
If you don't know, Hirsch is an American citizen
and his parents had been working tirelessly
to work towards a thieves fire
to get their son home. I had heard so many stories through social media,
just about what kind of man he was,
about his parents love for him.
So there is a deep sense of loss knowing that he will never come home.
And of course a few people came into my DMs to tell me that
it's a disgusting thing that I'm doing
to even recognize
um, these deaths when there's so many deaths happening in Gaza.
And the crazy thing is I have posted more about Gaza times 100
then I posted about the Israeli hostages
because
I felt that the weight of the devastation that was happening in Gaza
required more attention at this moment.
But I feel like I just have to say this.
I will not diminish anyone's humanity
in order to justify the violence of either side.
There's no justification for me
for the amount of devastation happening in Gaza.
And there is no justification for me for taking innocent hostages
and murdering people at a music festival.
You can disagree with me, but I think when you dehumanize people
and you take away the significance of their life and their death,
you are down A slippery slope.
So I can hold
empathy and grief for the innocent people being held hostage
and being killed,
and still hold empathy and grief for the thousands of innocent gossams
being bombed now too.
I still have two gofundme's in my account,
but I would really like to hit their goals and get their family
and them to safety.